il sillonne les couloirs vont de salle
en salle
leur mission aujourd'hui préparé
quelques 300 tables pour que les
candidats puissent passer l'épreuve de
philosophie lundi et de copie de
feuilles de brouillon
le rituel est le même chaque année
récupérer un maximum de place pas sur
les tables on va falloir qu'on ait
recule un peu autant que possible on
peut pas se permettre que les élèves
arrivent et qui est une salle mal
préparé ça va occasionner du stress donc
nous on fait très attention que chaque
élève et une place avec tout ce qu'il
faut pour composer on nous c'est vrai
que c'est important pour les élèves
c'est un jour de stress évidemment le
cpe règles l'heure accompagnée d'une
petite dizaine d'assistants d'éducation
il rappelle les consignes par des
affiches collées sur les murs plagiat et
objets connectés sont interdits un
détecteur d'appareils électroniques
pourrait même être installé au
secrétariat
la proviseure adjointe peaufine les
derniers détails c'est par série donc là
c'est le bac es
vous avez donc les quatre bacs
et puis les épreuves anticipées 4 la
préparation de l'examen dure depuis
plusieurs mois mais à quelques jours des
épreuves
la tension monte pour eux vérifient que
voilà les enveloppes qu'on va donner
c'est bien la philosophie de la série s
on relit de multiples fois parce que ça
arrive tous les ans quelque part en
france il ya des erreurs donc on a fait
en sorte que que ce ne soit pas chez
nous la semaine prochaine ses couloirs
vont se remplir comme dans tous les
lycées en bourgogne ils seront plus de
16000 à tenter de décrocher leur bac